[Music]
so there are oh there are various
hospitals available for unit testing and
testing mocking frameworks not just for
testing but also for executing the test
cases there are her integrated tools now
that help you script and execute in the
same software and then there are things
that help you create that harnesses like
when you have to do no tears or
performance steps you need to create the
virtual link or virtual connections
competitive selection to your
application or to your website so there
are hospitals that help you create these
virtual loads if you can simulate those
loads for you so that you can run them
when you need to do the testing and
finally the user interface playback tool
if you ever looked at automated testing
software it essentially does with
captures users movements when they're
trying to use a half there and report
that and then when you run that
particular automate is desk it's
essentially plays back what you have
recorded earlier so all the user
interface playback - there are various
office that you do this and find finally
packaging tools to better help you
package your software
there are repositories for example code
repository fossils
PDFs and the whole bunch of other gift
is a new one that is very popular with
the cloud and in the vault world
I've even have a github that is again
and integrators the software that lets
you do a whole lot of things basically
everything that you can potentially
think of in a software so when we get to
packaging and deploying troops the
newbies books apart and readily those
tools to help you have to convert your
code into an executable and container
management um you all must have perfect
familiar with containers in software now
especially the doctor coming into the
container management noodles again the
proper management tool is kind of a
container management insertion example
should we look at more of those and
deployment descriptors like the earlier
said you know deployment earlier used to
be a manual that where one person was
sitting sort of the computer and just uh
you know watch yourself Harry deployed
our lot of fur that is automated a lot
of that can be automated you know a lot
of that can be run towards quit where
you know you just redefine what steps
want to see for that need to happen and
you know these deployments
the Jewish spirit initiatives to create
visas for these different initiatives
automatically do deployments in one
environment or multiple environment at
the same time again different change
management systems a lot of your code
management systems also let you manage
changes in your software code in your
document they help you keep different
versions of your software code files or
document files or any other repository
files that you're using in your half
bear and then really the pool systems
again because this father to come like a
little high fever to be forces and all
this criteria is automatically
configured and Advan when it says photos
the system automatically captures that
the disease is ready for a deployment
and it has all the necessary tips done
for approval to deploy that rollback
mechanism which has been in place in
place for a very long time and you look
at the different rollback mechanism
Softail relieves automation tools I'll
just explain to you about that there are
a lot of software set up automated
release the build and deployment and I
know this was one of the impressed areas
that um it was the thing to know how we
can learn about that in this session so
we will do that and start scheduling
tools again via we had schedulers and
cron jobs with what we put all in the
past so we have more of those now so
we'll look at those in the view of Devon
and cloud in this session and finally
the integration to stare you know your
typical computers connect to your cloud
computer in the your virtual machine can
be integrated with a physical computer
or can be derived from a physical
computer we've all integrate and
enterprise integration tools will help
all different hardware systems computers
to get integrators and come together
you know to form a complete holistic
environment for a company configuration
and monitoring tools so people who come
from an operation pattern will be very
comfortable and familiar with the way
they they're like whole for a bunch of
different configuration and monitoring
tools that I use in production or in a
UAP environment and that essentially our
production support team had been looking
after all these years so they'll look at
more of similar tools for infrastructure
configuration and management
infrastructure as code to so we'll cover
all these things in detail as of the
requests racing to performance
monitoring tools we look at specific
software's and what they do and what
they allow you to do with how they mmm
how they help you analyze the
performance of an application or a vet
right alongside analysis every every
application every part as I tried every
function generate a lot of log files and
there are software and tools that look
into these ourselves and generate the
right alert for the people monitoring
that it's something needs to be looked
into something is one right there
there are software's that let you do
that enough co-efficient reporting there
are software that automatically take any
issues or any alerts generated
instigated the ticket or issue into a
into the corresponding software system
that you using
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here